from the tail of a boxer's Redemption to
a stripper's last hurray the first half
of 2023 has produced a number of films
that made much less money than their
producers had hoped Renfield opened to a
measly 10 million dollars on a 65
million dollar budget facing stiff
competition from other April releases
like the Pope's Exorcist and the Super
Mario Brothers movie given that the
character of Dracula has had a haunting
Legacy in horror for the past Century
viewers who came to watch Renfield
expecting a scary movie were
disappointed to find that the comedy
aspects were a bit too dominant to most
I am known simply as
right Fields boss
horror films are known to be profitable
at the box office given their generally
low production costs and high demand
from fans Renfield faced direct
competition from the Pope's Exorcist
which was made on a much lower budget of
18 million dollars and was solely
focused on delivering a horror
experience and it ended up with a
worldwide gross of nearly 75 million
dollars as a result additionally
Universal's decision to release Renfield
just a week after their own commercial
Juggernaut the Super Mario Brothers
movie could be deemed questionable
highlighting the lack of faith the
Distribution Company may have had in its
Scrappy horror comedy the Pope's
Exorcist producer Jeff Katz took to
Twitter to say looks like the Pope's
Exorcist is coming in ahead of Renfield
to debut in second place this weekend
beating our direct competition who had
double our marketing spend and more than
three times their production budget is a
nice little win cats continued in
another tweet the moral of the story is
that genre pictures should generally
only be made for a smart price whole
point is to be able to hit singles and
doubles and still potentially come back
for more hopes will be profitable for
Sony entirely because of this approach
Shazam truly did face the fury of the
box office Gods this year breaking in
30.5 million dollars in its opening
weekend Shazam Fury of the Gods had the
worst opening for a dceu film that
wasn't released during the pandemic with
a worldwide take of just over 130
million dollars on 110 million dollar
budget and with another 100 million
dollars spent in marketing costs it
would be an understatement to say that
the film was a box office disappointment
a growing sense of superhero fatigue
among audiences lack of positive word of
mouth and mediocre critical reception
are just some of the reasons that
contributed to Shazam 2 flopping the
announcement of a rebooted DC Universe
by James Gunn and Peter saffron may have
lowered audience interest in existing DC
EU narratives and competition with the
Super Mario Brothers movie and Dungeons
and Dragons honor among Thieves proved
to be a fatal blow to Fury of the Gods
this wasn't a surprise for director
David F Sandberg however who made a now
deleted comment on Reddit saying I saw
where this was heading a long time ago
I'll be all right though I got paid all
my money up front lead Stars Zachary
Levi tweeted his own take on the film's
disappointing reception writing I think
the biggest issue we're having is
marketing this is a perfect family movie
and yet a lot of families aren't aware
of that which is just a shame
it's all about
foreign
65 is an original science fiction film
that's not part of a larger franchise a
rare creature these days Adam Driver and
Ariana Greenblatt play a Starship pilot
and young girl as their ship crashes on
a dinosaur infested Earth forcing them
to adapt to the perilous habitat of our
prehistoric Planet the film's marketing
banked on drivers fan following so much
so that the film has colloquially been
referred to as atom driver 65 to make up
for an ambiguous and rather Bland title
the problem driver star power hasn't
necessarily proved to be a box office
draw outside of the Star Wars sequel
Trilogy especially considering that the
budget for 65 was reported to be around
91 million dollars this expensive film
was also released in March 2023 a month
when audiences had several other films
to choose from for their Cinema going
experience 65 competed with franchise
flicks that many fans eagerly looked
forward to such as Scream 6 Ant-Man and
the wasp quantumania and Creed 3. along
with remnants from the previous year
posting boots The Last Wish and Avatar
the way of water the poor word of mouth
and critical reception didn't seem to
help either
guy Ritchie's films have always been hit
or miss his 2019 Disney live-action
remake of Aladdin grossed a little over
1 billion dollars worldwide while his
historical Epic King Arthur legend of
the sword from two years earlier turned
out to be a major box office
disappointment Richie's latest spy flick
operation Fortune ruse De Guerre proved
its poor Fortune with the Meeker 3.1
million dollar domestic opening and a
worldwide gross of 37 million dollars
against an estimated 50 million budget
the film's poor box office showing
wasn't surprising however as many trade
experts foretold its inevitable
Financial Doom operation Fortune was
marred with multiple delays in its
release it was initially slated for
January 2022 release before it was
delayed until March due to a spike in
kova 19 cases through the United States
after that it was pulled again
indefinitely this time simply due to bad
luck as it turns out the majority of the
film's villains are Ukrainian a
coincidence that producers felt was in
four taste considering the ongoing
Russian invasion of Ukraine financial
problems also plague Production Studio
STX with its merger and restructuring
further putting the release of operation
fortune in doubt as a result the film
suffered from poor marketing and its
final release date was announced just a
few weeks before its March 2023 release
this gave the film very little time to
build any hype for audiences amid Hefty
competition
God damn it I do the stunts you shoot
the money
wake up everybody
since its release in mid-april Beau is
afraid has made a total of around 10
million dollars on a budget of 35
million dollars a24's most expensive
film to date with such a large budget
for an indie project writer director
ariaster was given complete free reign
to paint grandiose Strokes of his
distinctively absurdist style
unfortunately this creative freedom may
have doomed it in the end as many
critics and audience members found the
three-hour epic to be overly
self-indulgent in its presentation it's
not unreasonable for a24 to have
expected big returns from Masters third
outing Not only was this project
bolstered by the star power of Joaquin
Phoenix but the director's previous two
films proved that there's an audience
for his unique brand of movie making in
2018 hereditary made over 81 million
dollars on a budget of 10 million
dollars and 2019's Midsummer turned 9
million dollars into 46. compared to
Bose afraid the budgets for both these
films were quite modest a major factor
in their profitability even though Beau
is afraid topped the 2023 Indie box
office with a record collection of 320
396 dollars from four theaters in its
opening weekend it's likely that the
film will go down as a huge financial
loss for a24
we don't mean to pick on guy Richie but
audiences simply didn't flock to his
newest pair of films the way they did to
Sherlock Holmes the filmmaker's second
release in 2023 guy Richie's the
Covenant is his best reviewed movie to
date with an 82 rating on Rotten
Tomatoes however the film's critical
achievement was overshadowed by its
significant financial failure making a
worldwide gross of just 17 million
dollars on a bloated 55 million dollar
budget guy Ritchie's the Covenant is
nothing like any of Richie's other films
it's much more tonally grounded in
pensive without the wit or style that
the rest of the director's filmography
boasts even after attaching the
filmmaker's name to the title it failed
to drawn fans of other Richie films like
snatch and the Man from Uncle the bomb
could be blamed on the film's minimal
marketing as well as its distribution
model it was released in just over 2600
theaters Stateside with no theatrical
release internationally the Covenant was
distributed by MGM in the U.S while the
international distribution and post
theatrical streaming rights were
relegated to Amazon Prime Video making
it a direct streaming film in other
countries as with operation Fortune
Bruce De Guerre which was released just
a month earlier the Covenant was
produced by sdx films and their recent
financial problems also likely impacted
the film's marketing and release
with a 40 million dollar budget plus 20
million for marketing Magic Mike's final
outing proved to be the most expensive
as well as the least profitable in its
franchise while Magic Mike's Last Dance
taught the box office in its opening
weekend with a collection of 8.2 million
dollars the film ended its theatrical
run with the worldwide gross of 56
million dollars a far cry from the
profitability of its predecessors in
comparison 2012's Magic Mike earned a
total Global gross of 170 million
dollars while its 2015 sequel Magic Mike
XXL made a total of 123 million dollars
worldwide if you were to do
these just like
lying
how much would something like that go
for
Magic Mike's Last Dance was produced to
be an HBO Max exclusive but Warner
Brothers Discovery CEO David saslof
opted to give the film a wide theatrical
release however given that it had been
nearly eight years since the release of
the previous film audiences weren't as
Keen to catch up with the franchise as
the third movie shifted its focus to
Mike and newcomer Max's Romance the
ensemble cast that made the prior two
movies so popular was virtually absent
members of Mike's troop Kings of Tampa
appear only briefly at the end of last
dance which wasn't enough for those who
had been expecting their presence
big George Foreman the miraculous story
of the one sin future heavyweight
champion of the world Chronicles the
rise fall and Rise Again of boxing
Legend and entrepreneur George Foreman
produced on a 32 million dollar budget
which made it the most expensive project
of Christian Production Studio of firm
films big George Foreman was projected
to earn 5 million dollars in its opening
weekend but it only brought in three
while the high budget wasn't entirely
unreasonable the film's failure could be
attributed to inadequate marketing and a
lack of clear focus on its Target
audiences big George Foreman was split
on its advertising attempting to appeal
to both Christian audiences and sports
fans the film didn't win over either
group very well with the former
considering the film too mainstream in
the latter finding it too religious
faith-based films are generally produced
on Modest budgets which is a significant
component of their profitability it's
not like Christians aren't going to the
movies lions gates Jesus Revolution
grossed 52 million dollars on a budget
of 15 million dollars while the Indie
biblical tale his only son raked in an
impressive 12 million dollars from a
mere 250 000 with a total Global gross
of just 5.2 million dollars so far big
George Foreman shows no signs of
recovering its 35 million dollar budget
for nearly half a century author Judy
Bloom refused any offers for the film
rights to her best-selling 1970 novel
are you there God it's me Margaret that
change when producer James L Brooks and
writer director Kelly Freeman Craig
convinced the author that the two would
do the story Justice on the big screen
because I love the movie and how many
authors of the book can say I think that
movie is better than the book oh wow wow
while the faithful film adaptation of
the 1970 novel was released to rave
reviews from both critics and audiences
are you there God it's me Margaret open
to a disappointing 6.8 million dollars
it would be a difficult road for the
film to recover its 30 million dollar
budget considering that it's geared
towards a very specific audience despite
the story's Timeless themes the
non-contemporary 1970s setting could
have had a detrimental effect on the
film's appeal with its Target
demographic of young girls given that
the film primarily attracted women over
45 who grew up with the book rather than
its intended target audience of teen and
preteen girls lack of clarity regarding
who this movie was for may be the main
reason it ended up bombing foreign